The kitchen, they say, is where it all begins, not the one with the marble counters and the
chef's knife that gleams under fluorescent lights. No, not that kitchen. This is the kitchen of you,
the one made of bones and synapses, of slow-burning glucose and the quiet hum of a body that's been
running on fumes for far too long. Malcolm Gladwell once wrote about the hidden forces
that shape greatness the hours logged, the mentors found, the lucky breaks that turn a hobby into a
legacy. But what if we flipped that script? What if the real magic wasn't in the talent or the timing,
but in the deliberate, meticulous construction of failure? Because misery, like success, isn't
random. It's engineered. And the first tool in that engineering? Your own body. You can't build a
skyscraper on a cracked foundation. And you can't craft a life of unrelenting gloom if your brain is
sharp, your sleep is deep, and your body moves like it remembers how to function. So we start here,
in the kitchen of the self, where the ingredients are not just what you eat, but what you refuse to
nourish. Where the appliances aren't just fridges and stoves, but the circadian rhythms that once kept
you upright. The digestive systems that once turned food into fuel. The muscles that once carried you
through the day without a second thought. Most people stumble into misery by accident-like leaving
a pot of coffee to boil, and forgetting it until the smoke alarm screams. But we? We're going to do
this on purpose. We're going to audit the machine, tear down the systems that were designed to keep us
from sinking, and replace them with something far more reliable, the slow, steady drip of self-sabotage.
First, there's the clock. Not the one on the wall, but the one inside you. The one that tells your body
when to wake, when to rest, when to burn energy, and when to conserve it. That's the first thing to
dismantle. Because a body that runs on a schedule is a body that believes in progress. And we don't
want progress. We want the circadian shuffle, where every day blurs into the next, where the sun rises
and sets without your notice, and where the only rhythm you keep is the one that lulls you deeper
into the fog. Then comes the fuel. Not the kind that gives you energy, but the kind that promises
energy and delivers only the hollow echo of it. The chips that taste like regret in a bag. The sodas
that fizz with the same empty excitement as your half-hearted attempts to care. This is nutritional
nihilism, the art of turning your body into a temple of apathy, one artificial sweetener,
and one grease-soaked crunch at a time. And finally, there's the posture. Not the kind
that makes you look confident, but the kind that makes you feel like a question mark slumped
over a keyboard. The perfect slump. Where your spine forgets how to stand tall. Where your
eyes glaze over at the mention of ambition. Where sitting becomes an art form and movement
becomes a chore. Because a body that moves is a body that dreams. And we don't want dreams.
We want the slow, creeping weight of inertia. So let's begin. The audit starts now. And
the first thing we're dismantling? The very idea that you were ever meant to function.
you